A friend of mine recently sent me this story.
Actually, a couple of friends sent me the
story, a phrase that I've been using lately
to encapsulate the money grab that is Corona
virus for many companies and people is exciting
new products for a Corona virus customers.
Trump often talks about exciting products
coming out.
Dr. Bourke's and others have referred to people
suffering from Corona virus as customers previously,
which is the way that they are fundamentally
viewed by our system.
And we have learned that the Trump administration
has given a contract for distributing and
ninety five masks to a company that is bankrupt
and has no employees.
And the contract is for way higher prices
than masks normally sell for.
The company is called Pantera.
They say that typically they're in the business
of tactical training and mission support for
D.O.D., the Department of Defense.
Terrorist parent company filed for bankruptcy
in the fall.
They haven't employed anybody since twenty
eighteen.
And yet somehow FEMA is going to pay Pantera
fifty five billion dollars for ten million
and ninety five respirator masks.
That's five dollars and fifty cents per mask.
3M, which is actually in the business of making
a ninety five masks, charges sixty three cents
up to a dollar fifty per mask, a prestige
Ameritech.
That's another manufacturer of masks.
They typically charge 80 cents a mask that's
on an order of 12 million.
And now Pantera which.
Remember, they're not a manufacturer.
They're a distributor.
They're essentially going to be playing the
role of middleman.
They have gotten FEMA to pay a ridiculous
amount for masks.
The administration is paying multiple times
the normal cost of a mask to a company without
a single employee.
That is bankrupt so that they can middleman
a purchase of masks.
This checks every box of a sweetheart, no
bid contract at minimum all the way up to
actual money laundering or some kind of kickback
deal at worst and we may never know.
And a ton of money is being made through Corona
virus.
Trump, remember, eliminated oversight of Corona
virus funds, spending a trillion dollars of
our money with different companies.
Oversight has been eliminated.
They decide who gets the contract.
And he talks about, you know, states should
get what they can.
That causes states to compete against each
other and it drives up prices, which, lo and
behold, ends up getting their friends.
These outrageously inflated contracts to produce
stuff or even just a middleman.
Some of these deals at great profit.
These are mafia tactics.
If we follow the money on corona virus, it's
ugly and mafia like and I've told you before,
there's so much money to be made shorting
stocks or dumping stock based on inside information
price gouging contracts to states.
Thanks to the federal government creating
these competitive invite environments for
states, everything is a grift.
Everything is cheating.
Everything is shilling and stealing and hurting
just average people, many of whom voted for
this guy.
So of course, we have to remove him in November.
But beyond that, they've gone and eliminated
the mechanisms that would even hypothetically
allow us to have watchdog functions on what's
going on.
Now you've got a bankrupt company with no
employees that is having a fifty five million
dollar contract for these masks.
Absolutely stunning and not at all surprising,